prepare for the battle
[Music]
we
[Music]
it's monday i started a new project the
app is give her bubble it will be
comparing to get have users I'm willing
this product right now at the tutorial
later I will style it and add additional
functionalities but firstly LED bulb the
basics today I was learning how to set
up the web pack both web pack and j sx
both of these things are recommended
while working with react GS
[Music]
[Music]
yesterday I took pardon from the malacca
frankly speaking I thought I would learn
much more about as vgn d free but still
it was a nice introduction and simply
right now I have to dig deeper into the
fridge a ass and start building stuff
with it the example that was presented
during the meter used for simulation it
was pretty attractive but in order to
understand more you simply have to get
your hands dirty with the code and start
building sometimes they're all these
frameworks and libraries are too big and
and they are not the most effective
solution I'm learning a reactant order
to be able to to wagon it to build
bigger ops and use it when you need it
it's also the market that requires from
you the frameworks and right now i'm
practicing even the small apps in it but
but the truth is that sometimes vonage a
guess would be the simplest and the best
option and it wasn't wave so much so its
way of remembering when working with
frameworks such as angular or suggest
react GS
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's friday and the app is almost done I
want to check it on various devices and
browsers let's get back to work and
let's start testing
[Music]
[Music]
this is how the app looks at the end of
the week it's fully responsive on small
screens are horizontally that the home
spin looks a bit differently in order to
boost the usability their home screen is
centered with flexbox so it's got a bit
different layout than the rest of the
skis you can enter to users and compare
them you can start about 2 or reselect
players let's start a battle the loser
is always a bit rate out so I added the
filter as you see here if filter
grayscale one hundred percent and
opacity is a bit lower than done one so
it's 07 in order to differentiate who's
the winner and you can start over the
game whenever a user introduces the
names that are incorrect that are not
present in our github they get a
notification that warriors are
misspelled and and they come back to
player one spin so they are ready to
introduce new players and start the
battle
[Music]
the users chose the wrong players they
can reselect them and start the button I
built this graphic using free peek and
the whole idea for the app came from
react training and that is linked here I
also prevented the user from you know
clicking enter going farther or clicking
continue without providing the user name
because it didn't make any sense when
the players are the same the result is
of course a tie so I still find it buggy
to display it on edge and Microsoft's
Internet Explorer if anybody knows how
to deal with it was the problem I am in
a really open to the feedback in order
to do the changes maybe I'll find it on
my own too but so far I haven't I
started working on the sub on Monday on
the 7th of november and i started with
setting up the web back later few
comments later i styled it a bit more
introduce all the functionalities
additional functionalities and
optimizations you will also find this
link in the video description below so i
will provide this for you if you if you
want to play on the app the app is done
of course you can like iterative arrays
I'm gonna give big shouted for react
training i will put the link to the page
in the video description below react
training causes of much more courses at
this one other the world's using it have
bubble is for free so they can give it a
try and later decide if you want to buy
the rest of the courses or not for me
the big plans was that each step was
introduced really in details so i even
and there was something
knew I'd have to worry a lot because it
was explained and it was clearly
explains the only thing missing that in
this course was like sending it out to
the production when I used NPM run star
for the development server for the local
host the past were a bit different than
later in the production so I had to
change that the past in routing in order
to make it away but I managed to do it
there is another big thing next week I
won't be blogging because they will be
moving out and changing plans so I hope
to meet with you in two weeks and when I
come back I want to work on react
challenges from free code camp and i
also want to practice more of vanilla
JavaScript because still this is a thing
that I want to come back to keep on
doing stay motivated and see you in two
weeks time
[Music]